Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, today we're going to
continue talking about the
subject of biomechanics.
On Tuesday we talked about
properties of materials and
particularly elasticity and
viscosity and viscoelasticity.
So, you know something about
how biological materials behave,
at least in terms of how they
respond in terms of deformations
to forces.
Certainly there's a lot more to
learn about that but we covered
the basics on Tuesday.
Today I want to talk about
how organisms move,
and how they move through a
physical world where they have
to obey the laws of physics.
This is one important role of
biomechanics,
to sort of understand,
if you're thinking about human
biomechanics,
how humans perform as sort of
mechanical machines.
That's one important role of
biomechanics,
how organisms,
not just humans but all kinds
of organisms function in an
engineering sense.
A big part of that is how they
survive, and not only survive,
but prosper in a world where
they have to obey the laws of
physics.
It's interesting to try to
understand this because if we
understood sort of how the human
machine works,
for example,
under normal conditions you can
think about, 'How can I enhance
performance in certain
conditions?'
That of course is a big part of
exercise physiology is
understanding how humans work as
biomechanical machines.
What we're going to talk
about today with the example I
want to use as just an example
of this is motion in biological
systems.
In particular,
motion that humans can't do on
their own, flying.
Motions that we do all the time
walking, and a kind of motion
that we do occasionally,
some of us, swimming.
Think about how you would apply
what you know about physics to
understanding those processes.
Why, in general,
do organisms have an ability
move?
Think about organisms like us
or organisms like bacteria,
it's one of the essential
ingredients of life.
One of the ways that we
recognize that things are alive
is because they're able to move
from one spot to another,
so why is motion so important?
Why is motion important in the
life of a microorganism,
a protozoa, or a bacteria
that's swimming around in the
ocean, why should it move?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: To find nutrients;
to eat and to find the
nutrients or sub-straits that
are essential to its growth.
If you think about the
movements that you make during
the course of the day,
how many of them are motivated
by your need for food?
You move in order to find
things that you can eat and
that's one reason why living
organisms move.
Why else do they move?
Justin?Student: To
avoid danger.Professor
Mark Saltzman: To avoid
danger, to get out of harm's
way.
If you're a microorganism what
would be dangerous to you is
often chemicals.
There might be chemicals around
you that are toxic to you,
and so you'll swim to get away
from those chemicals.
If you're a rabbit in the
woods, you might be running to
get away from a fox or a wolf or
something that's going to eat
you.
If you're a human you might run
out of Prospect Street to avoid
getting hit by a bus,
that's a good use of motion for
self preservation;
one more key reason why animals
move;
essential for propagation of
the species, not just survival
of the organism.
Justin?Student:
Mating.Professor Mark
Saltzman: To reproduce,
they move to reproduce,
to get together and that might
be some of the reasons why you
move everyday.
Certainly in the animal world,
in general, movement for
finding mates,
for reproduction is an
essential part of it.
So, easy to see why movement is
critical, for not just the life
of a microorganism,
not just the life of a
multicellular organism,
but for survival of the species
as well.
Movement requires force and
we're going to think about
forces.
In particular,
the forces that an organism
needs to develop somehow or
generate in order to overcome
forces that resist motion,
so just some elementary physics
here which most of you probably
remember from high school
physics,
is that if an object,
the object here is this green
oval.
If it's going to be moving with
a constant speed what does that
mean?
Moving with a constant speed
means not accelerating.
There has to be some force
applied in order to create the
motion but the forces must
balance, so the overall forces
acting are zero.
For an object that's not
accelerating the sum of the
forces is zero because the
acceleration is zero.
If we think about this
green object moving to the
right, to the left,
to the--to your left then there
must be a force that's creating
the motion to the left and that
force is just big enough to
overcome the resistance to
motion.
That force is equally balanced
with whatever force resists
motion.
Of course the force that
resists motion is going to be
different if you're an organism
that's trying to fly,
than if you're an organism
that's trying to move along the
ground, than if you're an
organism that's trying to swim.
So, what we're going to think
about today are the forces that
resist that motion and how
organisms overcome that
resistance.
If we think about flight first
then the situation is a little
bit more complicated.
What's the force that
creates motion?
Well, there's got to be some
propulsive force that's moving
us--that's moving the organism
forward or to the left here.
There has to be some propulsive
force that opposes the force
that resists that motion,
and that force is drag.
It's drag on the object that's
flying the air and that drag
comes from the interaction of
the surface of that object with
the air.
It has to move air out of the
way in order to move ahead.
In order to move with a
constant speed,
there has to be a force that's
pushing it to the right and that
force has to be exactly opposite
to the drag force which is
resisting that movement.
That drag force comes from
displacement of air,
friction of air.
You have experienced this
drag force if you are driving in
a car and you stick your hand
out the open window,
you can feel the force that's
pushing your arm backward.
In order for you to hold your
arm straight out you have to
apply a force in the forward
direction that's directly
opposed to the force that's from
the air that's pushing your arm
back.
As the car goes faster,
it takes more force to move it
ahead, it takes more force to
hold it steady.
So, the amount of force that
you need to apply varies with
the speed that you go.
The faster the car is going the
more force you have to apply to
hold your arm out steady,
the faster a bird flies the
more force it has to apply in
order to overcome this drag
force that's opposing its
forward motion.
That's the dynamics,
that's the force balance in the
horizontal direction;
propulsive force overcoming the
drag force.
You know it also depends on
shape.
If you hold your arm out this
way, you hold your arm out this
way, you feel a different force
from the air.
The shape or the profile of the
object that's in this field also
matters, keep that in mind as
well.
If you're going to fly there's
another force you have to
overcome and that's the force of
gravity.
That's the force of gravity
that is pulling you down towards
the Earth.
To overcome that force,
that constant force,
there has to be a force that's
moving up.
If you're going to maintain a
constant height,
a zero velocity up and down was
what you would need to maintain
a constant height,
then you'd have to have a force
that's lifting you up that's
exactly opposite to the force of
gravity.
If you're going to fly you have
to have that upward force as
well.
What kinds of objects can
fly?
Planes can fly,
this is a picture of an old
fashioned plane.
Maybe you've ridden on a plane
that has a propeller on it,
maybe not, but it's a little
bit easier to describe this way;
that the forward force that
overcomes drag is provided by a
propeller that spins and creates
a force in the forward
direction.
In order to move at a constant
velocity, depending on what that
velocity is,
you have to overcome a certain
amount of drag and the propeller
spins at a speed that will
provide that force to move
forward.
That seems, if not a complete
description, that seems like a
pretty adequate description of
how you move ahead.
How do you get off the
ground and maintain off the
ground, maintain your height off
the ground?
In order to do that,
you have to overcome this
constant force of gravity which
is pulling you back.
That's the main problem with
flight, overcoming the force of
gravity and in airplanes that's
done through design of wings.
A typical, sort of airfoil or
wing design is shown here.
What happens is it's using this
flow of air, this constant flow
of air over the body,
over the wings for example,
by changing the shape so that
there's more surface area on top
of the wing than there is on the
bottom.
You change the relative
velocities that air can move
over the wing,
over the top of the wing versus
over the bottom of the wing,
you create a flow separation or
a disturbance here where the
pressure drops relative to the
pressure in the ambient air.
The pressure drops because
of this turbulent air flow
pattern.
If there's less pressure here
than there is down here,
you get a force acting up,
pressure is force per area.
If there's a difference in
pressures from top to bottom,
more pressure on the bottom
than there is on the top,
you'll have a lift force going
up.
You can fly if that lift force
is large enough to overcome,
or at least balance the force
of gravity.
Does that make sense?
You can imagine that that lift
force varies with speed that
you're moving through the air.
For example,
there's a critical speed you
have to reach before you get
enough lift to take off and that
lift force depends on the design
of the exact shape of the wings
or the airfoil,
certainly depends on their size.
If I've got bigger wings and
pressure's what's moving me,
force is pressure per area,
bigger wings more force up.
The basic physics here is
fairly straight forward,
although implementing this took
some time,
people have been trying to fly
as long as there were people
watching birds.
It took awhile for us to figure
out how to implement this and to
implement it as reliably as we
can now.
How do birds do this?
How do birds fly?
Well, birds don't have
stationary wings,
typically.
Although their wings can be
stationary;
if you watch a hawk or an eagle
or a large bird,
they glide for a lot of their
flight once they're airborne.
If you watch,
my office overlooks the Grove
Street cemetery,
there's some hawks that live in
the cemetery,
must be a good place for hawks.
T hey take off and then they
glide for long periods,
they can circle and there's
very little motion of their
wings.
They're basically
doing--they're taking advantage
of the forward thrust that they
have created and they're
coasting but their wings are
doing this.
They're holding their wings in
a position that creates an
airfoil, creates the pressure
drip to move them up.
To take off or to create
this forward thrust they move
their wings, they don't have
propellers.
So, they use their wings to
create thrust by sort of pushing
them against the air backwards,
by creating a forward thrust
which overcomes the drag.
Yet their wings are shaped like
an airfoil so they create
thrust, they bring them back
into the airfoil position,
and they get lift.
So, it's more complicated than
what I'm describing but you can
see beating your wings like
this,
creating thrust in one
direction, holding them in a
position where you create lift.
Then, varying between those two
things you can both move forward
and supply the lift you need to
overcome the force of gravity.
If you watch different kinds of
birds you'll see that they
execute different kinds of
patterns, and they do that
because they're different.
Some birds are smaller than
others, some are bigger,
some have different shaped
wings, different shaped bodies.
So, their particular motion is
adapted to the physics of their
body and their need to move it
through the air.
I talked a bit about wing
size.
Wing size is one thing that you
could use in an airplane,
for example,
bigger wings,
more upward lift.
Bigger wings,
of course, heavier.
So, if it's heavier it's going
to require a bigger engine so
that you can get the thrust
needed to move at a certain
velocity.
If you look at birds of
different sizes,
or flying animals of any kind
of different sizes,
you'll notice that there's a
correlation between the size of
the wing and the size of the
animal.
The bigger the bird,
typically, the bigger the wings
for just that reason;
bigger bird heavier,
needs more lift in order to get
up into the air.
You also notice other kinds
of adaptations;
that birds that have big wings,
big bodies, also tend to have
strong legs.
Little birds,
isn't it amazing,
little birds you see perched on
a tree limb or something,
very small legs.
Big birds, hawks,
falcons, eagles,
strong legs;
why would a big bird need
strong legs?
Well, they actually pick up
prey and things and so they use
them for acquiring food,
that's a good reason.
Why do they need them for
flight?
They need to be able to lift
off and so to get that
initial--maybe they get some
boost from their legs in the
lift off phase,
some forward thrust and some
upward lift, just from the
muscular structure of their
legs.
They're not always in flight,
they need to land sometimes and
they land on their legs
typically.
If you're going to bring a big
object down to the ground
there's going to be some force
involved with that.
You need large legs in order to
survive that force.
Just giving you some examples
of how the physical structure of
animals is adapted to their
function and a lot of it is
their function as mechanical
objects.
It's a familiar concept but one
can sort of break it apart.
An interesting kind of bird
is shown here,
a hummingbird;
have you ever watched a
hummingbird?
Hummingbirds do something
that's really amazing,
they hover, which means they
can stay up in the air without
having any forward thrust.
When I was talking about the
airplane example or even the
bird example,
I was talking about using the
forward motion supplied by
thrust in order to create the
pressure drop that brings you
up.
But if you stop moving forward
that pressure drop disappears,
you go down.
Forward motion is required for
an airplane to stay up in the
air, for a bird,
most birds that stay up in the
air.
Hummingbirds can hover
which is a remarkable physical
achievement, and they do that
because they can actually turn
their wings in both directions.
They can turn them upside down
and that's shown in this diagram
here, that they can make the
wing go backward and forward,
and turn it right side up and
upside down, so they can create
a motion where they're creating
no net forward thrust or
backward thrust,
but always creating lift
because they're changing the
position or the orientation of
their wings.
More complicated than that,
if you're interested I'm sure
you can find information on it,
but again they can do this
because they have specially
designed wings that can flip
over during their motion.
They have the muscles that
allow them to make this kind of
a motion, and they're fairly
small so they don't need much
lift force in order to keep them
aloft to overcome the problem of
gravity.
Hummingbirds can hover because
they generate lift in both the
upstroke and the down stroke.
As long as their wings are in
motion they're constantly
creating lift,
and so they stay off the
ground.
That's something about flight,
which is interesting,
and I think maybe the simplest
one to think about because one
can break down the forces that
are involved fairly easily.
Let's think about walking
and running, or a mode--nobody
flew here this morning,
you got here to class somehow,
how did you get here?
Most of you probably walked,
maybe some of you ran,
but most of you probably
walked, why?
Of all the choices that you had
why did you walk instead of
slithering on the ground or
crawling, or running?
Why did you walk?
Why did you make that choice?
You might didn't have even
thought about it,
you probably didn't get to the
room--to the door of your room
and say should I crawl,
slither, run,
or walk you probably just
started walking.
Why was that your first choice?
Justin?Student: It
seems natural.Professor
Mark Saltzman: It comes
naturally.
Why do you think that's your
natural motion for moving along
the surface of the Earth?
Why is that your natural choice?
Why have you decided,
even without thinking about it,
that that's your normal mode of
motion?
Yeah?Student:
[Inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: It's the easiest,
it's the least resistant,
it's the most efficient way to
move from one place to another,
and its efficiency that's
important.
Now, how would you define
efficiency here?
How much energy did you need to
expend to get from your room to
here and how can you get from
your room to here minimizing the
amount of energy that you spend?
That's the subconscious
decision that you make and the
answer is that you walk.
What force are you
overcoming when you're walking
here?
What's the force that opposes
your motion?
The force that creates your
motion is the movement of the
muscles or your leg and your
skeleton.
So, like rocking back and forth
like this I'm using my muscles
to create motion side to side,
and you use a similar strategy
when you walk.
What force am I overcoming when
I do this?
What force did you have to
overcome in order to get here?
Well, you're not--there is a
drag force because you're moving
through air.
So just like a flying bird,
you're experiencing drag from
the atmosphere but it turns out
that that's not as large as the
frictional force of your body
touching the ground.
When you walked you probably
didn't walk like with your feet
on the ground because that would
take a lot of energy.
Try it, try walking back home
with your feet constantly on the
ground, that takes a lot more
energy than picking them up.
You pay a price for picking
them up.
Now, you're introducing another
problem, actually two problems,
in that when you pick up a foot
you have to overcome gravity,
so you're using some of your
motion to go in the wrong
direction.
Instead of moving towards class
you're moving up by picking your
leg up, which is not getting you
any closer to where you want to
be.
You pick it up in order to
release from the frictional
forces that are holding it back,
the frictional forces that
resist motion.
How do you walk then?
You don't walk with your feet
constantly in contact with the
ground, although that would be
easier in a sense,
because if your feet are both
on the ground balance is not so
hard.
Once you lift a foot off the
ground the other problem it
introduces is balance.
It's much harder for me to stay
stationary on one leg than it is
on two legs because gravity is
acting on my body and trying to
pull me back down again.
An additional problem arises
with this lifting up of one foot
and that is the problem of
balance.
How do we solve that?
We solve that by controlling
our muscles, the muscles that
move us from side to side maybe,
but that takes energy.
I want to move forward and
the easiest way is to walk and
you probably didn't think about
it when you were walking here
today but you're doing a fairly
complicated set of operations.
You're lifting one foot off the
ground to avoid gravity,
and you're letting it swing
forward.
The heel of your forward foot
hits the ground,
your foot then moves,
the toe of your back foot
leaves the ground,
swings forward,
heel strike,
toe lift, swing,
one foot's always on the ground
when you walk.
You don't think about it but
it's a fairly complicated motion
that you can do automatically
now,
but if you do think about it
when you're walking to your next
class, you'll notice that one
foots always on the ground.
That helps you solve the
problem of balance.
What else happens when
you're doing this motion?
You might not notice it at all
but you're pelvis is actually
undergoing a fairly complicated
set of movements.
I'm going to exaggerate it so
you can't laugh.
If you watch somebody else walk
or you put your hands on your
pelvic bone, the pelvic bone is
this sort of girdle that both of
your hips are connected to,
you've seen it on a skeleton.
When I lift up my leg then I'm
tilting my pelvis up,
I'm tilting this side up in
order to get the leg off the
ground.
I'm also bending my knee a
little bit to make my leg
shorter, and I'm moving my foot
in order to allow,
when the toe lifts off,
allow it to swing without
hitting the ground.
You don't want to hit the
ground because of friction,
that would be a waste of
energy,
you want to lift it just enough
so that you clear the ground and
you do that by tilting your
pelvis up and by bending your
knee a little and manipulating
your foot.
You let that leg swing
forward, the toe hits,
and now you're doing something
else with your pelvis,
and that you're going like
this.
You're not only lifting up to
get it off the ground,
and then up on the other side,
you're also twisting it like
this, so your pelvis twists,
your pelvis tilts,
and it actually undergoes--if
you could put a sort of--I'm
exaggerating it--not as much as
others could but I'm trying to
exaggerate that your hips sort
of go through a figure-eight
kind of motion as you're moving
forward.
It's a fairly complicated
motion that you do without even
thinking about it because you've
done a lot of walking and you've
learned how to do it very
efficiently.
Does this make sense?
If you look at the
efficiency of walking you are
creating forward motion,
you're creating it in
opposition to friction.
You're doing it by lifting a
foot off the ground,
freeing it from friction,
swinging it forward.
The cost is you had to spend
some energy going up,
and then you recover that
energy when you come back down.
What's energy called that you
store as you move up?
Potential energy;
so one of the other things that
happens, if you notice somebody
walking, and it's hard to notice
if you just see me walking like
this,
maybe you can,
but my head is actually moving
up and down when I walk because
my center of gravity is rising
and falling as I pick my leg off
the ground and let it swing.
You can't see that so
easily when you're watching a
whole--have you ever seen
somebody walk with a fence in
front of them and you see their
head and it moves up and down a
little bit?
There's an inter-conversion
there between potential energy
when I'm up and kinetic energy
when I'm down.
I can exaggerate that way too
if I walk funny.
You're putting some of your
energy into potential energy,
creating potential energy with
your muscles,
and then recovering that when
you come back down.
The more of that you have to do
the more energy it takes.
These movements of the pelvis I
mentioned before sort of smooth
out this up and down movement,
so you're not wasting so much
energy going up and down,
you're mainly going forward.
If you walked--did anybody
walk here with somebody?
Did you walk by yourself or did
you walk in--anybody walk in a
pair?
Nobody wants to admit that they
walked some--well have you ever
walked with somebody else?
Did you ever notice that
sometimes when you're walking
with somebody else they want to
go faster than you or they want
to go slower than you?
Why is that?
Why do some people walk more
slowly than others?
quickly than others?
Their legs are longer so their
bodies are shaped differently.
So, they've figured out how to
make their walking efficient for
them and that means they've
figured out how to do this
motion with their body in the
most efficient way.
Now, why would longer legs
make it more efficient to move
faster?
Well, because when you swing
your leg you get a bigger bang
for the buck,
you get farther with one
stride, that's part of it.
The other part is that your
leg, when it's in this swing
motion, behaves like another
object you probably studied in
physics, the pendulum.
You've seen pendulum's that
swing, you notice that the
timing of pendulum's--anybody
have a metronome?
Metronomes are pendulums like
that, too, that have an
adjustable weight.
If you move the weight one way
or the other,
then the pendulum starts
swinging at a different
frequency.
Depending on the length and
weight of your leg,
as a pendulum,
it has a natural frequency at
which it wants to swing.
If I want to walk with the
least energy possible I want to
just let my leg swing.
I don't want to put any energy
into it, I'll put some energy
into lifting it off the ground,
but once I lift it off it's
back here, what if I can just
let it go and it swings forward?
That's the most efficient
motion.
That motion would have a timing
that depends on the size of your
body and the length of your leg,
and the weight of your leg,
and all the other
characteristics that are
particular to you.
If I want to walk slower than
my natural state,
I have to slow something down.
My leg might swing forward fast
with a certain distance.
In order for me to move slower
I have to actually slow down my
leg.
I have to slow down the swing
forward, that takes energy,
it takes muscles to slow down,
and so sometimes you feel like,
if you're walking more slowly
than you want to,
that it's actually taking more
energy than it should.
Likewise, if you have to walk
faster than your normal pace,
it will seem like and will be
that you're using more energy
than you would like to.
Walking has an efficiency;
you can change your speed of
course, you've learned how to do
that.
If you plot on a graph,
like this one,
this is a graph for a typical
person who's walking on a flat
outdoor surface.
What it shows--the blue line
there shows the efficiency,
or how much energy you use as a
function of speed of walking,
how much energy you use as a
function of speed.
So, there's a flat part at the
beginning, not too much
different.
If I'm below two miles an hour
walking it takes about the same
amount of energy.
But as speed goes up,
the energy consumption goes up.
You have to walk faster,
faster than your natural
stride, and so you're using more
energy maybe to swing your leg
forward faster so that you can
walk.
You might even,
if you start walking fast,
try this on your way to the
next class or try to walk with
somebody and watch them,
as you walk faster your head's
going up and down more.
You're taking advantage of this
potential kinetic transition to
get more speed,
but the cost of that is that
you're moving body up and down
more and so that is less
efficient because movement up
and down is wasted.
At a certain point,
you see the blue line goes up
and up and up,
and it's exponential.
If you--it starts to look
exponential.
If you continue to try to walk
faster and faster it's going to
eventually start to become
really uncomfortable.
You're naturally going to want
to switch to a different form of
motion and that's running.
Now, you can avoid that and you
could try this yourself,
try walking faster and faster,
and faster and don't let
yourself run,
just walk faster and faster,
and pretty soon you're doing
the crazy kind of walk that
Olympic fast walkers do,
that feels very unnatural.
You might get a lot of speed
but it feels very unnatural.
I'm not--you're kind of--can
anybody do it?
You've seen it.
You're moving up and down a
lot, your pelvis is doing a very
unusual pattern,
not the subtle movements that
it does during normal walking,
but it's moving a lot more.
That's what you notice,
the fast walkers they're moving
from side to side,
they're pelvis is really moving
a lot.
It becomes quite
inefficient because you're
wasting energy.
In fact, your body is telling
you to make the transition from
walking into running.
If I want to move at this speed
it's more efficient for me to
run, and that's what this graph
shows you as well.
If you extended the walking
line up a little bit,
at a speed of about 5 mph,
running becomes more efficient
than walking.
You can feel that transition if
you try to walk fast.
There will become a point,
at about 5 mph,
when you're going to want to
start to run because that will
feel like a more efficient way
for your body to move.
Now, what is it that causes
that, mechanically,
that transition to take place?
What's different about running
than walking?
Well, one of the things
that's different is that you
don't always have one foot on
the ground when you're running.
In fact, if you watch somebody
run or you run yourself,
you'll know that for a lot of
the time you're only--you're
not--no foot's on the ground.
There's not time that both feet
are on the ground,
one foot hits,
you sort of bounce off of it,
you bounce off the other one,
you're sort of hopping off one
foot.
Try to do that slow it's really
hard.
Why is that hard?
Because it's hard to balance on
one foot, it's impossible to
balance on no feet when you are
standing still.
As your speed increases you
create inertia.
You create forward motion,
and that forward motion or
inertia stabilizes your body.
It makes balance less of an
issue.
If you're moving forward at 5
mph, you're not worried about
sideways motion so much because
you have this forward motion
which is going to continue to
carry you forward,
and balance isn't so much of a
problem anymore.
You can sacrifice having both
feet on the ground.
You can even sacrifice having
any foot on the ground for some
period and you'll just fly and
you'll fly forward no balance is
required,
so you're not spending any
energy on balance.
Running is sort of like
flight in a way,
only it's very short flight.
It's like flying and hopping,
hopping on one foot.
Also at that speed,
when you're moving at 5 mph,
if you see somebody that's
running,
particularly an experienced
runner, and what makes
experienced runners better than
inexperienced runners?
They've become more efficient
at doing this running motion and
so they can move at fast speeds
very efficiently.
One of the things you'll notice
in very efficient fast runners
or good runners is that there's
very little up and down motion
of their head even though
they're hopping and flying,
they're not moving up and down
very much.
They've learned how to do this
without moving very much in the
gravitational field,
keeping their center of gravity
about the same which allows them
to convert all of their energy
into forward motion.
Does this make sense?
There's another peculiar
thing on this slide and it's the
black line, cycling.
If I told you that you had to
move this afternoon at 12 mph to
get from here to somewhere else
in New Haven in a couple of
minutes,
most of you if you had the
choice would choose to use a
bicycle to do that rather than
walking and running.
Particularly if you knew you
had to move that fast you'd pick
a bicycle.
It won't be surprising for you
to see that cycling is much more
efficient at higher speeds than
either walking or running,
so if I want to move 12 mph,
cycling is much more efficient
than running;
walking is not even shown here
because it would be so much less
efficient.
On the other hand it
doesn't make obvious sense
because you're going to agree to
move fast,
not with your--not only with
your body but with another thing
as well, which adds weight.
Even a very lightweight bicycle
weighs 30 lb.
So, you're adding 30 lb to your
weight but you would gladly do
that if you knew you had to move
fast because you know it's going
to be efficient.
Why is cycling so much more
efficient than running?
Well, one reason is when you're
cycling you're sort of a in a
constant profile.
You're moving your legs but
your center of gravity stays
relatively uniform,
very little up and down.
All of your motion,
all of your energy that's
created by your legs is
converted into forward motion.
The other thing you know is
that now you have a
mechanical--you have a machine
that's going to convert the
energy of your legs efficiently
into motion of a wheel and that
wheel overcomes friction very
efficiently by actually using
friction.
It's friction between the wheel
and the ground that keeps the
bicycle stable and allows it to
generate high speeds.
This machine allows you to
overcome the problems of
friction and gravity very
smoothly, and so cycling is a
much more efficient activity.
A lot has been written about
the biomechanics of cycling if
you're interested in learning
more about that.
Well, I want to talk about
swimming, another mode that we
use, not everyday.
Some of you might swim
everyday, most people don't.
Microorganisms that live in the
ocean, fish that live in water,
of course swim all the time.
Swimming is their primary mode
of motion and they swim to get
food, get away from danger,
reproduce, all of those things.
What's the major problem that
you have to overcome when you
swim?
Well, it's friction or drag,
it's the same problem really
that all movement has to
overcome,
but we're not thinking so much
about friction on the Earth now
we're thinking more about the
drag force that's created from
moving through a fluid.
It's a bigger problem now
because the fluid is viscous.
Air has a relatively low
viscosity;
you know what viscosity is from
Tuesday's lecture.
Air has a relatively low
viscosity, water has a higher
viscosity, molasses or honey has
an even higher viscosity,
but it's harder to move through
water than it is through air
because it's thicker,
it's harder to slip the plains
of packets of water passed each
other to go back to the
description I gave you of
viscosity last time.
In fact, if you're going to
swim at a constant velocity,
then you have to create a
propulsive force moving forward
that is exactly opposite to the
drag force that is created by
moving at that velocity.
Just like the example of
putting your arms out of a
moving vehicle,
which I don't recommend.
I'm sorry I'm using it as an
example because we've all done
it but I don't recommend
experiments of that kind.
Imagine that you're putting
your hand out in water,
the same kind of thing would
happen,
only the force would be even
greater because of the greater
viscosity of the water.
You have to create a bigger
propulsive force in order to
overcome this drag.
That's what fish have to do,
that's what microorganisms that
swim have to do.
Most microorganisms that
swim for a living or most fish
that swim for a living have
evolved mechanisms to move
quickly through water by
reducing their profile,
so fish often have streamlined
shapes.
They might be flat.
The look like flat plates
sometimes, some kinds of fish.
That's an easier shape,
a more streamlined shape
creates less drag as it moves
through water than a bulky shape
like a cube or a sphere.
Streamlining or shape is an
adaptation that animals can use
in order to move faster.
You know this if you swim,
if you want to swim and just
glide through the water,
push off from the side and just
glide, if you go like this
you're not going to glide very
far.
If you put your hands in front
of yourself or down at your side
and make your body more
streamlined you're going to go a
long ways,
so streamlining helps.
It turns out that there's a
very simple relationship between
the drag force and the velocity
that you move forward for
objects that are spherical or
roughly spherical.
I show that equation here.
The drag force is equal to 6 pi
times the speed or the velocity
that you're moving times the
viscosity,
times the size--and here the
size would be the radius of the
sphere (F_d=6
vr).
This equation applies to
spheres.
It applies very well to objects
like microorganisms,
like bacteria that aren't
entirely spherical but they're
not too different from spherical
either.
If I am this bacterium and I
want to move with a constant
speed, I have to create a force
that exactly overcomes this drag
force that's created and that
drag force depends on speed.
To move faster I have to
overcome a bigger drag force,
I have to create more
propulsive force just like the
airplane.
A fish the same thing,
in order for it to move forward
at a certain speed,
it has to overcome the drag
force and it does that by moving
its muscles,
by moving its flippers and fins
to create a propulsive force.
What I did here is a simple
calculation between different
kinds of swimmers.
Swimmers that are basically
different in their size.
For a bacterium it's very
small, its size is .0001 cm,
that's about 1 micron,
so a very small object.
I asked the question how
much--if I ask the question,
'How much drag force is created
for it to move at a certain
speed?
' What was a reasonable speed?
I picked a speed of 10 body
lengths /s;
10 body lengths /s would be a
speed of .0001 cm/s,
so just multiply this by 10 /s.
The viscosity of water is .01
centipoise or .01 g/(cm*s).
If you knew these factors,
you knew how big the bacterium
was, you knew the viscosity of
the medium it's going through,
you knew how fast it was going
to move, you could plug into
this equation and calculation
the drag force.
If you calculated the drag
force, that's how much force
that object has to be generating
in order to move.
You could do the same thing
for a fish.
Now, a fish is bigger,
let's just say lots of
different sizes of fish.
Let's say a 10 cm fish moving
through the same medium,
moves 10 body lengths /s that
would be 100 cm/s.
A Yale student who wants to
swim might have a size of about
170 cm, larger than the fish or
the bacterium.
To move 10 body lengths /s,
I converted that to mph,
that's about 0.5 mph.
I'm not a swimmer, is that fast?
Sounds fast;
it's slower than you normally
walk, but you can't swim as fast
as you can walk.
Let's just use that as an
estimate and it's moving through
the same viscosity.
One of the things that I asked
you to do in the homework for
next week is to take this data
and sort of consider what life
is like for a swimming
bacterium,
for a swimming fish,
for a swimming Yale student,
just with these factors in
mind,
their sizes,
viscosity being the same,
and their speeds of motion
somewhat different.
You'll have a chance to think
about this quantitatively for
next time and we'll come back to
it in section.
I want to finish by talking
about another element of
biomechanics that I hope I'm
able to talk a little bit more
about a couple of weeks from
now.
That's the issue of design in
biomechanics,
and one of the main issues of
design in biomechanics is the
design of artificial
replacements for joints like the
hip.
Artificial hip replacements
have now been around for
hundreds of years.
W e are quite skilled at making
artificial hip replacements,
surgeons are quite skilled at
doing them.
A surgeon who does a lot of hip
replacements can do an operation
like this in about an hour.
That includes taking your
diseased hip out,
putting an artificial hip back
in, and getting you to the
post-op all in about an hour.
It's a pretty remarkable
achievement from the surgical
side.
I want to show you a little
bit about how these work from
the biomedical engineering side.
To do that I first wanted to
show you the hip joint,
which you might have seen
before.
This is skeleton,
this is half of the pelvis I
was talking about before,
it's motion during walking.
You see half of it here,
so this is the person's
midline, this is the right hip,
the pelvis, the crest there.
If you put your own fingers on
the sides of your hips,
you can feel the bone that sort
of sticks out at the top about
where my belt lies here,
that's the crest of the ileum
or one of the bones that makes
up the pelvis.
For the experiment,
you're going to do while you're
going to your next class where
you think about how your pelvis
moves,
keep your fingers there that
will be convenient and silly if
you walk that way.
The hip is connected right
below that.
You can feel--if you feel down
a little bit from the crest of
your ileum, you can feel this
part of a long bone called the
femur that makes up the thigh.
It's the bone of your--the
upper part of your leg.
That bone extends down to your
knee this way and it connects to
your pelvis this way,
through a structure that's a
continuous structure of the bone
called the femoral neck and the
femoral head.
What it looks like is a neck
and a head.
The head being sort of a ball
and the ball of the femur fits
into a cup in the pelvis,
and it is this ball moving in
this cup which gives your hip
its range of motion.
Your hip has remarkable range
of motion, you can move it all
different sorts of ways.
Not just forward and backward,
but you can move it to the
side.
It's the ball moving in a cup
that creates all of this
versatility of motion;
you can swing it around
different ways.
Well, when this joint gets
diseased, movement becomes much
more difficult.
In general, it's a degenerative
disease that the bones and the
cartilage start to break down,
and so now this cup and ball
don't move so smoothly over one
another.
When they don't move smoothly
over another,
they generate friction,
they generate pain.
So, degenerating hips can cause
tremendous amounts of pain for
people.
What's in between these
two--this is just a skeleton so
there's nothing in between these
two,
but in our hips what is it that
lubricates the space between the
hip of the cup in the pelvis and
the ball of the femur,
what lubricates that space?
Well, there's some fluid there,
but the main thing that
lubricates it is protective
layer of cartilage or soft
skeletal material.
Not bone but a soft spongy
material that lubricates between
bones, and that can break down
in diseases like arthritis.
Well, this is what an
artificial hip looks like.
The modern hip is composed of
two parts, there's a cup which
goes into your pelvis that
replaces the normal structures
into which the femur goes.
So, it replaces the cartilage
and the bony structure around
the pelvis, and the end of the
femur,
the neck and the head are
replaced by a piece of metal.
The metal sets in the metal
ball of the femur,
the artificial femur sets in
the cup of the pelvis.
Now, what lubricates it now is
not cartilage but a polymer.
Because if you had a metal cup
and a metal femur going in,
metal on metal,
even if it was very smooth
metal,
that's not--there's friction
associated with that motion.
If you put a polymer,
in particular,
what are used most often now is
high density polyethylene or
something like Teflon,
a metal ball slides very easily
over a Teflon cup,
particularly if they're
machined to fit together
precisely.
So that's what is used
currently and what allows normal
motion to be restored.
Now, the problem,
the main problem here is how to
get this ball and this neck
attached to the femur.
Because, if you think about it,
why is it metal?
It's metal because if you're
standing on one leg all of the
weight of your body is on that
one leg.
The whole weight of your body
is on the femur,
the whole weight of the body is
actually right here.
The whole weight of your body
is on this very small--depends
on the integrity of that very
small piece of material.
What we learned last time
is that materials have
elasticity.
You don't want something that
bends a lot there.
You want something that's
strong, that doesn't bend,
even when there's a high stress
applied to it like the stress of
the weight of your body.
Metals are really the materials
that best can supply that kind
of mechanical strength,
that kind of resistance to
bending, resistance to fracture.
The problem is how to get this
on here.
The way that that's solved,
currently, is to have the neck
and the ball of the femur
attached to a much longer piece
of metal.
When you get an artificial hip,
then this part of the new
replacement femur goes down into
the bone of your leg,
inserted into the bone so that
it's more stable.
There's all of this metal into
your bone to sort of stabilize
it because the last thing you
want,
or what you want to achieve,
is for this part of the femur
to move without any slippage
with the rest of your femur.
I'm going to come back to this
concept later and talk more when
we talk about artificial organs
about how artificial hips are
made,
but I wanted you to at least
have a picture of how this
particular piece of biomedical
engineering works.
We'll see you at section this
afternoon.